Le RAID, l'élite de la police.
Des super-agents surentraînés,
leur devise : servir sans faillir.
- Suivant !
- Bonjour.
Ah, c'est pour le secrétariat, l’infirmerie ou la cantine ?
Je suis là pour le groupe d'intervention du RAID.
C'est un danger pour le groupe, une gonzesse.
Une femme, Froissard...
Ça crie, ça chiale, ça se pète les ongles, ça se coince les cheveux dans le casque...
Bon, on a une femme, c'est comme ça !
Oh non ! Pis ça a tout le temps envie de pisser !
On a pas les combinaisons adaptées pour les pisseuses !
Effectivement, vous n'êtes pas du tout macho.
- Je me suis trompé.
- Oui !
Vous êtes seize, il y a quatre lits par chambre.
Faites-moi tout de suite quatre groupes de quatre, s'il vous plaît.
Alors, ça, c'est un groupe de seize !
J'ai parcouru son dossier, elle a de très grandes qualités.
Tu connais, ça ?
Ah, ça énerve, ça !
Euh... cachées.
Double !
Et le fait qu'elle porte le même nom que le Ministre de l’Intérieur ?
Mais ça n'a rien à voir. C'est sa fille, mais ça n'a aucun rapport.
Je vous préviens,
à la première occasion, je la vire !
Il faut aller la chercher, là !
Non, c'est bon ! Regarde, elle fait encore des bulles !
Bloup, bloup, bloup !
Aouh !
Pardon !
Là, elle est éliminée, elle a...
Ah ben non !
Ben, euh, l’ennemi est neutralisé, là !
Eh !